Freiburg im Breisgau – mit seinem
Wahrzeichen, dem Münster,
ein guter Ausgangspunkt für eine
Tour durch den Schwarzwald.
Bekannt ist die Studentenstadt auch für ihre
Wasserrinnen, die sogenannten Bächle,
die die Altstadt durchfließen.
Michael Gihr hat hier Germanistik studiert.
Im Sommer macht die Region so attraktiv,
dass es einfach ’ne
vielseitige Landschaft ist.
Man kann wandern, Fahrrad fahren.
Das Wetter ist meistens toll hier im Süden,
und man kann abends draußen
in den Cafés sitzen,
gemütlich was trinken,
das Wetter genießen.
Das macht’s so schön.
Nicht weit von Freiburg
liegt das Glottertal,
für einige Besucher der Inbegriff
der Region Schwarzwald:
das Klinikgebäude „Carlsbau“
– es bot die Kulisse für die Fernsehserie
„Die Schwarzwaldklinik“.
Von 1985 bis 1989 schalteten
allein in Deutschland
jede Woche um die
25 Millionen Zuschauer ein.
Die siebzig Folgen um Chefarzt
Professor Brinkmann und sein Team
wurden in 38 Länder exportiert,
von Ungarn bis nach Südafrika.
Die Zeiten, in denen Fans der Arztserie
das Glottertal geradezu überrannten,
sind vorbei.
Das Café Schill erinnert weiterhin an
die Dreharbeiten und die Schauspieler.
Fritz Schill wurde durch die Serie
vom Frisör zum Souvenirverkäufer.
Wir hatten sehr, sehr gute Jahre,
was in der Zwischenzeit natürlich
die Normalität jetzt erreicht hat,
aber heute noch leben wir von den Leuten,
die deswegen noch zu dieser Klinik pilgern.
Südöstlich des Glottertals liegt der Titisee,
ein beliebter Badesee.
Ja, der Wettergott verwöhnt
den Schwarzwald
oft mit vielen schönen Sonnenstunden,
und deshalb kann man in einem
der zahlreichen Seen
auch wunderbar baden gehen.
Gerade Familienurlauber schätzen den
fast 40 Meter tiefen Badesee,
einen von rund 30 im Schwarzwald.
Der Schwarzwald hatte schon
im Mittelalter seinen Namen,
da er so tannen- und fichtenreich ist.
Der Holzreichtum spiegelt sich auch
in den heimischen Produkten wider.
Am bekanntesten: die Kuckucksuhr.
Bereits 1730 soll es die ersten
Kuckucksuhren gegeben haben.
Die Firma Rombach & Haas in Schonach
produziert sie seit mehr als 100 Jahren.
Angefangen hat’s mit dieser Variante.
Man nennt das Schilderuhr, handbemalt
– also das ist der ursprüngliche
Kuckucksuhrentyp.
Und wir jetzt, unsere Firma,
hat vor sieben Jahren
’ne weitere Variante ins Leben gerufen,
nämlich modern.
Also wir machen jetzt auch
hochmoderne Kuckucksuhren.
Und die schlagen alle.
Diese Uhr ist fünfzigfach vergrößert.
Als sie 1980 erbaut wurde, war
sie die größte Kuckucksuhr der Welt.
Auch der typische Schwarzwaldhut
mit den vierzehn roten Bollen
ist in Schonach größer als normalerweise.
Nebenan in Triberg stürzen die vielleicht
bekanntesten Wasserfälle Deutschlands
mehr als 160 Meter in die Tiefe.
Im Süden des Schwarzwalds: der Feldberg
– mit rund 1500 Metern
der höchste Berg der Region.
Am Schwarzwald fasziniert
mich die gute Luft,
hier jetzt das schöne Wetter,
die Landschaft einfach.
Mich begeistert die Natur.
Man kann wandern, Rad fahren.
Es bietet einfach sehr viele Möglichkeiten.
Vom Aussichtsturm reicht der
Blick bis zu den Alpen.
Zurück in Freiburg:
Michael Gihr arbeitet abends
in einer der zahlreichen Kneipen,
ein idealer Ort, einen Sommertag im
Schwarzwald ausklingen zu lassen.